- Thanks for the drive, Zeke.
- OK, Dak, enter the casino. You just need to win one—
- OK, tell Dak he just needs to win—
- OK, tell Kellen Moore to tell Dak to win.
- [Announcer:] Interception!
- [Jerry Jones:] Careful, you're surrounded by serious threats.
- So, uh, my dude. What are the rules?
- Oh, I thought you had done this before.
- I call.
- I ain't call back, though.
- Wait, I have to play Tom Brady?
The Bills get to play against Skylar Thompson.
- Go fish!
- No, no, no. Go Bills.
- [Dak:] And I don't even know who is left for Baltimore.
- You're Ray Lewis with a fake moustache.
- Man, I said I'm No-Name Johnson.
And I lettered at Minnesota Southern.
- OK, daddy needs to recoup massive crypto losses.
- Looks like Brady's tell is that every time he's inconvenienced,
he destroys a tablet.
- Stupid thing givin' me bad cards!
[Banging and shattering]
- Call.
- Ah, once again, bested by my enemy...
DVOA.
- How'd I do?
- Wait, wait.
- [Together:] Is this kid, like, really good?
- Hey, man...
- [Together:] I love your hair. Jinx!
- There, there. You're coming with me.
- OK, let's see your cards.
- We won.
- Please give me some privacy as I publicly mull retirement.
- Shaken not stirred, what the f**k is that?
All we have is warm Yuengling and water.
- Um, I can make you a burger if I can find you a grill.
Oh, they left.
- You know, I used to coach the Eagles.
- Very cool.